[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
excuse me
I was looking for the weekly volcano
office I wish to see mr. Dashwood a
friend of mine desired me to offer story
by her she she wrote it she'd be glad to
write more of the suits not a first
attempt I take it no sir she has sold to
Olympic and scandal and she got a prize
for a tail at the Blarney Stone banner a
prize yes sit
we'll take this oh you will with
alterations it's too long
but you've cut I took care to have a few
of my sinners repent the country just
went through of war people want to be
amused not preached at morals don't sell
nowadays perhaps mention that to your
friend what compensation what how do you
we pay twenty five to thirty four things
of this sort will pay twenty four that
you can have it make the edits should I
tell my my friend that you'll take
another she had one better than this
will look at it tell her to make it
short and spicy and if the main
character is a girl
make sure she's married by the end or
dead either way
excuse me what name would she like put
the story oh yes not none at all if you
please just as she likes of course oh
good morning sir good day
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon is mouch oh good
afternoon you're on fire thank you
you're on fire thank you I haven't seen
honey do you see Oh giddy and Minnie are
waiting oh my students need me always
working money is the end the name of my
mercenary existence no one gets ink
stains like you oh just out of desire
for money well my sister Amy's in Paris
and until she marries someone obscenely
wealthy it's up to me to keep the family
afloat goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
the decadence of ruined Paris if you ask
me this French women couldn't lift a
hairbrush Amy I said these French women
couldn't lift a hairbrush
oh yeah very true Martin don't you
mermaid girl what do they write your
troublemaking family no there doesn't
say anything about that I feel I should
go back but they all say stay you can do
nothing if you go back the girl is sick
not lonely and you shouldn't go home
until you win Fred thore not properly
engaged yes and until I've completed all
of my painting lessons of course yeah oh
yes yes of course
[Music]
[Applause]
are you brought so much recognize you
because you're so beautiful you like
that sort of grandfather he's in Germany
he's still traveling I'm traveling on my
own now it's relaxing yes well don't
tell your mother are you chasing some
young girl across Europe no I
I couldn't believe Joe turned you down
I'm so sorry don't be he me I'm not baby
[Music]
come to the New Year's Eve party the
ball and everyone will be there
including friends pick me up in the
hotel at 8:00 the sugar Oh dress for
festivities
I will I'll wear my best silk
it's Laurie I know
[Music]
20 yards of the blue silk as well as the
pink someone will be by for it later
oh hey that would look so lovely on you
I know just the dressmaker to send you
to you'll be the prettiest wife in
conquer I John needs a new coat for
winter and Daisy and Demi need new
clothes and his wife needs a new dress I
can't it's I just can't he'll be so
pleased with how you look well forget
all about the expense I don't suppose it
that's a bunch of extravagance well 20
yards do yes
go play
[Music]
[Music]